Applying the Java plugin is simple.
We only need to add a single
line to our build script.
Now if we run Gradle tasks, we see
a whole wealth of capabilities that
the Gradle Java plugin can handle for
us.
There are four main tasks we'll
use most often, assemble, build,
clean and scrolling down a bit
we'll use the test task as well.
Assemble creates the output
we're interest in.
This is usually a jar but
can also be more interesting artifacts.
Check runs any tasks we've set up.
Build depends on both assemble and
check.
Finally, clean deletes
all the build output.
We've got a trivial Java
project in this folder,
with a single class called person.
Let's try running Gradle assemble.
Looks like it's done.
Looks like the build directory
contains another four directories.
Looking in the newly
created build directory,
we find a classes subdirectory,
which holds our compiled classes.
And a libs subdirectory,
which holds our newly created jar.
Now you might be thinking to yourself,
I thought there wasn't
going to be any magic.
This sure seems like magic.
How did Gradle know where
to find my source code?
I promise there's no magic.
Gradle just has a lot of
very sensible defaults.
Like, for instance,
it assumes that your JAVA sources live
in a folder named source name JAVA.
This, like most everything else
in Gradle, can be configured,
and we'll show how shortly.
There's another important
thing to know how to do.
And that's run
the project we just built.
You might have noticed that the Java
plug-in doesn't add any tasks for
running your code, and
that's because the JavaExec task type is
already part of the core
Gradle functionality.
The main property tells the JavaExec
task the path of your main class.
And we'll talk about this class
path property very shortly.
If we go ahead and
run this task, there we go.
We see our task running, and
then we see a greeting coming
from our newly compiled Java.